so you don't have a house and you were
living in one of the rooms and I was
able to see that by renting out these
rooms he was making quite a decent
amount of profit do you think your dad
had done my HMO call I really wish my
dad knew you back then I'll remember
Ricky contacting me there's this guy
called Muhammad we need to get him on
the academy he's gonna blow up I get
deals coming to me a week before they
will go to market I get first dibs on
them over the last few years it's been
about 50 deals that I've done so my
whole mentality of being on estate agent
for six months just changed and I was
able to do a deal yesterday at 200 000.
they started off saying they wanted
around about 210 215 Mark every single
property that I own now is approximately
giving me a thousand pounds profit a
month
so the reason I wanted to interview
today is because you own 20 properties
you've sold hundreds of deals you've got
your own estate agency I mean you're a
massive implementer you went on the
lease option boot camp like a week ago
yeah and then straight away bang bang
started securing lease options and I
wanted to just really get your story and
hopefully draw some lessons and
inspiration for the viewers here so why
don't you start by just talking about
how you got into property in the first
place so originally what happened is my
dad had a property that he owned in red
ink um and he was renting out four
individual rooms in the property and in
the fifth room I stayed in that in that
fifth room so around about 400 pound a
month was coming in per room so I had
about 1600 pound coming in there and I
had 1600 pound coming in for my my wage
from my job I very early on realized
that there is a market here where rooms
are able to rent out in in reading so
that's how I saw so your dad had had a
house that's right and you were living
in one of the rooms but you were kind of
helping your dad and you saw the money
that's right yeah so dad's mortgage was
only about 200 pounds and I was able to
use his method and see that by renting
out these rooms he was making quite a
decent amount of profit right you know
do you think your dad had done my HMO
course I wish I really wish my dad knew
you back then
um so we'll be well ahead right now so
how did you go from that then to like
movie I mean your dad was in property
did he have a lot of houses no no so dad
just had the only one this is another
residential you know we were still
living there but he moved abroad and um
and I started I just I just ended up
staying in the house and just renting
out the individual rooms so what were
you doing as a job I was training to be
an accountant at the time oh yes how did
you go from that which is your dad's
house to you getting on the property
ladder and you building your Empire I
think very early on I realized how the
passive income that was coming from
dad's property and for my job I realized
how that's taking up a lot of my time
whereas the passive income was making me
the same sort of money
so I realized I wanted to do more of
that and that's when I first bought my
house next door to Dad and I did exactly
the same okay I rented out the
individual rooms and I was able to earn
quite a decent amount of money from that
at that time it was quite easy to get a
mortgage it was yeah times back in 2000
2007 2008 were a lot easier but then the
crash came so I bought the most
expensive house in West Reading so it
was difficult but it always rented out
so I never really worried about the
crash because so it constantly kept
renting so I wasn't really that bothered
even now people were worried about
um a crash happening but it doesn't make
a difference because your properties are
still rented out they're still going to
be producing income for you that's such
a good point so basically even if you
buy a house and the house price drops as
long as it's producing passive income
wait for it to go back up again that's
right that's right and even if interest
rates go up and they are going up and
people are worried however
it makes no difference if a property is
making you profit yeah that's the main
thing and the thing is people are
worried because they're doing the math
and they're saying for buy this house
and rent it out I'm hardly gonna make
any profit but if you went out room by
room or as you've been doing more
recently serviced accommodation then
actually you can still make considerable
profit yeah so that's how you do it you
buy like you know a lot on your course
you've taught us how to buy refurb
refinance
that is the method if you really want to
build a portfolio and that's how I've
done it over time I've bought I've
refurbed I've either sold or I've
remortgaged and bought more properties
how many properties do you own I know
you control a lot of properties but how
many did you own right now in total is
around about 20 properties and that's
including with including jv's that's
awesome and and how many did you control
I manage around about 500 properties
across the country damn when did you
start deal selling I've actually been
deal selling since uh it's been about 10
years I started in Reading actually
interesting but when I started deal
selling in Reading I was doing hmos and
it was exactly what I knew what I was
doing however the market became very
saturated in reading and so I stopped
deal selling and the reason why I
stopped deal selling is because I was
only specializing in hmos and I stopped
because if I couldn't rent out the
property for my client then I wasn't
gonna I wasn't gonna be a bad deal
sorcerer and offer them something and
realized that they couldn't run their
properties out so I stopped it suddenly
and then I've started restarting about
four about four years ago mainly in
different locations like Liverpool
Preston and Coventry and that's when I
started building up a portfolio again of
new clients over the last few years I've
done around about been about 50 deals
that I've done for for investors um how
much do you charge on average anything
from three to six thousand pounds are
you doing 50 in the last couple of years
see that alone is like a really good
income if you just did that and nothing
else oh yeah you'd be very you'd be very
wealthy with our business what we're
doing is we're offering a a turnkey
service so we help find the investment
we help uh we help project manage if
there's any refurb that needs to be
doing we will also rent the property out
we'll manage the property we help them
refine so you're getting paid every step
of the way but also you're making your
hands off for the investor we are we're
making it completely hands-off because a
lot of people don't have the time they
want to they want this to be as passive
as possible and we are that solution for
being as passive as possible that's
awesome what about as well BRS what do
you think about bureaus in this market
brr in this market you know my recent
example is we bought something in
Liverpool for 270 000 we are spending
around about 120 000 in refurbishing the
property but we are looking to
remortgage that property around about
half a million pounds so hang on you
bought it for how much 270. how much
you're spending on it about 120. so in
total 390 and then envo is 500 and a
half million pounds yeah
my guy when did you find it I found it
in November how how did you find it
through an estate agent but it was a
good one that I had really built up a
relationship with and what I was able to
do is I actually
the great thing with the Liverpool what
I was able to do was able to find
tenants before I purchased the property
so I have tenants move in on the first
of July this year I was then able to
secure the property I purchased it in
March started the refurb which should be
complete everything should be completed
before the first of July how do you find
the tenants before you even buy the
house I was able to show them examples
of other properties that we have in the
area and say this is what your property
will look like but this is the one we're
buying for so now you you know what the
what the rent's going to be it passes
all the stress tests you've not got any
void periods
small question who are the tenants
students why would they change their
mind and I'll find some more students
right but but they're all on one AST
Amazon so they are paying 135 per week
per person just over three and a half
Grand that's not bad bro yeah so what
are you buying bras aggressively
yourself and packaging number seven and
if so how do you decide when you keep it
yourself and when you package yourself
no I I don't I don't make any difference
uh my for me it's making sure that I
can't I can't go around buying
everything I'd love to be able to do
that but I have investors who are really
good investors that want the sort deals
so anything that I find I've even found
the same deals on the on the same roads
that I'm purchasing on that I will sell
to one of my clients where do you find
the investors to sell the deal I think
mainly through my state agency a lot of
the people that have built relationships
over the time a lot of my clients come
through the estate agency can you
legally as an estate agent charge a fee
to the seller and the investor or that
be a conflict of interest it is a bit of
a conflict of interest however what I'm
doing is is my my deal selling business
is completely separate from my state
agency sure so you're not charging like
a fee to the seller and a charge
charging the fee to the investor you'll
deciding okay this is and that's another
thing about people people sometimes say
why would I pay a deals also when I can
just go to an estate agent and the
answer is because an estate agent's
obligations which is a seller and
they're working in best interest of the
seller their intention with the estate
agent is to get the highest price
whereas if you're paying a deal saucer
their job is to get the lowest price so
the fee that you might pay them three
grand you're going to save way more than
that through their negotiations 100 and
that's what it comes down to it's
negotiating the best price you know that
is one of the things I do quite well
where I'm always going playing tennis
with the with the estate agent I'm
saying right they might say this
property is worth 210 I'm saying no I
think it's 190 so let me start off my
offers at 190 or a little bit less and
then build it up and I was able to do a
deal yesterday at 200 000 for a property
that they would they started off saying
they wanted around about the 210 215
Mark so I still got between 10 and 15
000 pounds off what they originally
wanted and you're right it's a buyer's
market now the market is beginning to
change it is and it's changing and I
think you've just got to be on top of
that everyone's moaning about the
interest rates and stuff oh interesting
to hire all this but it's like hang on
the fact that everyone's moaning means
that they're not all buy-in and the fact
that not everyone's buying means that if
I'm buying I can choose what price I pay
exactly it's just buying the right way
and and don't be scared about investing
right now because if you're if you're
buying in this market you're refinancing
in this market you're in this market
already as long as you're getting the
right rents then you're doing really
well so yeah why was it only a few
months ago when you met me came to the
train and joined the academy what why
why now so some of you you firstly kept
on coming up on my Tick Tock I kept on
seeing you pop up and I thought right
this guy really knows what he's doing I
I follow I followed you I was watching a
lot of things that you're doing I
thought this guy I've never ever been to
see any Mentor before or done anything
this everything I'd done was on my own
however seeing what you were teaching
and how you were implementing and the
way you put yourself across to everyone
that's what attracted me so I said I
have to go and learn more tell me the
story then so what happened so you see a
tick tock video what happened no I just
saw the tick tock video and then I
actually contacted you through
um
through Tick Tock I'm pretty sure I
tried to contact you through Tick Tock
never got into a response I don't
respond on tick tock
so many thousands
I
have to gram yeah but as soon as I start
responding on Tick Tock it's going to be
a whole new but maybe I should so sorry
about that and then I actually got
through on your website and that's when
I emailed in and they booked me in for
the discovery day so I came first in
Discovery day met my team I met your
team I met Elia he was great and that's
when I I sort of thought okay I think I
need to do this but I had to run it past
my sister my sister is sort of in charge
of making sure the financial decisions
are made right
um so I do like to run things past her
she does work in my company but she is
someone I remember Ricky contacting me
I'm saying there's this guy called
Muhammad he's already really successful
we need to get him on the academy he's
gonna blow up but we didn't manage to
get him he left he didn't register for
anything and he said he needs to speak
to his sister and normally when people
say they need to speak to the system in
our mind you know what it's like in
business we think we'll never see them
again never see them again but no I came
back on the next Discovery day with my
sister and Taz as well Tasman mortgage
broker and we will decided that it was
the right thing for me to do and for us
all to do actually so they will be they
will be on as well uh very soon another
question that's interesting for you as
well is you're making a profit of about
25 Grand a month you've got a lot of
properties you're quite wealthy why was
it such a big decision joining the
academy because for some people joining
the academy is a huge amount of money
but for someone in your situation it's
not a huge and it's still an investment
but why was it such a big deal why did
you need to keep coming back and I think
for me it was I wasn't making a huge
amount of money at that time when I made
the decision to join I was actually
making quite a big loss through my
essays the essays were making me huge
losses and that was where I struggled a
little bit I wanted to find new ways and
methods of how to improve so the essay
one was the most attractive to me at the
time how were you losing money during
the winter months yeah they wouldn't go
they just wouldn't go on on and I was
making a lot of mistakes number one I
was only using Airbnb so I didn't have a
channel manager I didn't I wasn't with a
Vivo I wasn't doing anything of the sort
and I wasn't even using booking.com so
that was one of the things
a lot of people think that you just
stick it on Airbnb and wait and do
nothing but actually this is a business
it's about having it on the right online
travel agencies pushing it marketing it
properly it's a business yeah so it was
those things that I realized straight
away I needed to do
um go learn about more about essays and
how to manage things properly and those
on your course I was able to do that and
implement the right things and and team
up with the right people I've actually
teamed up with Academy members in
working and making sure that the ones
that I do currently have are working
successfully why do you think the
service accommodations become so popular
over the last few years it was something
was missing you know I go when I go to
Liverpool I stay in hotel I used to stay
in hotels a lot of the time but having
the extra space and having having been
able to you know go to places where
you've got your own cooking facilities
you've got your own space is having that
extra space that I think people really
really needs I think so as well and for
me when I travel I like to travel with
my family my wife and kids I've got
three kids
we can't stay in a hotel even if we get
a hotel suite there's not enough space I
can't be having my kids in another room
so it makes sense to book it like a
two-bedroom apartment a three-bedroom
apartment or a small house for a few
days and where can you do that well you
can do that with people's service
accommodation properties another thing
is as well what do you think of all the
changes like section 24 the tax changes
uh tenants rights scrapping section 21
like as somebody that's in the business
I mean what do you make of how much of a
bashing it is it seems like everything
is constantly against landlords
everything is against us trying to you
know we are providing great
accommodation and they're really nice
renovated properties they're nice
properties but the government hasn't
allowed us to do the right thing they're
always stopping us from just making the
right steps and I just it's it's
something that's making it really
difficult for landlords however
there are ways which you know you need
to just make sure you're doing it the
right way and learning to do it yeah and
I think that's another thing as well
what worked 10 20 years ago in the
property Market might not quite work in
the same way today I mean if labor
getting they're talking about having a
um a register with all landlords having
to be on the register we know there's
probably going to be even more
legislation with the tax changes I think
it is becoming harder to just shave up a
deposit buy a house rent it out but the
buy Select Market I don't think it's
dead I think there's a place for it and
I think you can still make money doing
it but it's not as lucrative and as easy
as it was 10 years ago every year seems
things seem to be getting tougher and
tougher and um you know I know that just
conversations of how again no tax relief
on the interest payments so people are
going to struggle but the methods that
you're teaching us the way of how to do
things and and if we Implement them in
the right ways yeah then then we should
be successful well that's the thing with
service accommodation you can get tax
relief and people don't realize this
it's not just about getting more profit
it's about also navigating through some
of the legislation of course they might
they're just like short stay let's at
some point I'm sure they will but it's
always about keeping up isn't it and
being creative and adapting so it's what
happened then so so you joined the
academy after spending a long time
thinking about it getting advice from
your sister your accountant your lawyer
your dog
what happened it was making those losses
those winter months making seven
thousand Pounds loss a month during the
winter months so I was really feeling
the crunch yeah so money that I was
making on my hmos was being pumped into
the essays lost that I was making such
that's where I decided that I need to
make a change and that's when I came on
board started listening to everything
you were teaching I spoke to the likes
that even Darcy she was fantastic now
I'm going to be looking forward to
seeing what happens this winter but I
have other options you know so I have
ideas and I know what I have to do to
implement it so as soon as I see some of
the red flags I know what changes to
make however I don't think I'm gonna get
to that position because already making
those changes as we speak so that's
already turned a corner every single
property that I own now is approximately
giving me a thousand pounds between 800
to a thousand pound profit a month
that's great it's really has turned the
corner and I'm really really pleased
with it so what's happening so when did
we first start training together I
started about three months ago so what
happened in the last three months just
anything you've taught me I've just gone
back and I've implemented it and those
are the changes I needed to make and
that's the main thing for me it's
implementing the things that you've
taught so anything to do you know even
with the essays it's going with the
channel managers it's been on the right
platforms so these are things that yeah
I could have probably learned outside
but being told and taught by you and the
way you simplify it that really helped
me and you do simplify things I think a
lot of people like the way you make it
so easy you make it so straightforward
for us to be able to understand how to
deal with it well yeah because I'll have
to I've said this to you before man I'll
have to sit with like an accountant for
instance you know how accountancy works
because you trade was one and I'll be
paying them the hourly rate one-on-one
for seven hours trying to get to the
bottom of understanding something and
then after seven hours I'm thinking why
didn't you just expand it like this and
I'll summarize it and they'll be like oh
that's true and then I'll go and teach
that to my students and they'll just get
it and now we have to then teach it to
we have to make sure our accountants
understand that this is the right way of
actually doing things you've given us a
lot of education for us to then go and
implement it and feed it back to the
people that are doing our accounts and
doing yeah and doing a challenge will
account challenge your solicitor people
think obviously says I need to pay 10
grand stamp Duty or just to pay it no
understand the rules and do you actually
have to pay it and that there I've never
you know I think I have bought a
property previously which you know
didn't have wasn't completely habitable
but I never I never really thought about
that again that's another thing that a
lot of people don't realize they just
think they have to pay stamp Duty and
many people probably have but again on
your course these are the things we were
able to learn so I highly recommend
people to come and join your course to
be able to learn more about how to make
things more effective if they're in the
property world or getting into the
property world how to implement and do
it the right way from the beginning well
that's a real compliment and especially
code for someone like yourself that's
got so many years in the business what's
your reasoning what's your strongest
reason for doing this what is it that
gets you up in the morning and keeps you
pushing and striving on your business I
love the passive income I love being
able to you know I was with a friend a
long time ago and he said to me the best
thing about the properties are just
waking up and knowing that you've made
money you might wake up and you've got a
booking you might wake up and you've
received rent it's just constantly yeah
ticking over so I think having passive
income and having an income from
properties there's no better income to
have rather than you working your nine
to five working your ass off for someone
else you're actually doing it for
yourself yeah that's the beauty and
you're able to buy things with it you're
able to do things that you want to
achieve and and and give your family a
better life what are your goals now then
where's the next level for you I want to
grow my business so my company is called
Mr sales and lettings
um we are based in reading and Liverpool
um we have properties in Preston
Coventry Lancaster a few other places
that we are targeting at the moment but
I want to be Nationwide and like my
estate agency to get to the position
where we are across the country and we
are helping find the right Investments
for the clients and going all the way
through to managing them and that's what
we've been doing for a number of years
but I think now I'm able to grow bigger
and better a lot quicker and just do it
ethically as an estate agent then
someone who owns an estate agency what
are some tips that you would say to
investors that are coming in what are
some of the things that they should stop
doing because when I worked as an estate
agent you know I did it for only about
six months you you see things different
from a different perspective and now I
cringe some of the stuff that I used to
do so what are some of the things that
investors do how they talk to agents how
they approach deals which they should
stop I think with estate agents number
one
you know even when I when I first went
into
um Liverpool so in Reading I was I got
to know people quite well but when I was
first taking on properties it was really
difficult to gain and build
relationships with the state agents
um they didn't really want to do
business with me it took me a while but
what I was able to do is I sort of went
to them and said look I'm an investor I
have investors behind me we are looking
to buy properties and we're looking to
push up you know to to get as many
properties as possible it was only when
I did a deal with one estate agent and
bought 13 properties off one vendor who
had 13 properties to sell and I had 13
clients to buy every single one when I
did that it was only then I I made a
name for myself and then I got
recognized but I think for people when
you're getting into this business you
need to know what you're doing and how
to do it and you need to be around the
right people so I think coming to your
training has helped me and I think
giving people that confidence in making
the right steps and doing it the right
way that's the most important thing yeah
I think that's so true and I used to
always say
the best way to build a relationship
with an estate agent is to buy from them
because if you buy a deal through an
estate agent you're now a client and
you've made that as that agency money
and then they'll be potentially passing
you more and more deals because they
know you're serious at the moment I get
deals coming to me a week before they
will go to market I get first dibs on
them because you're an estate agent or
because you know what to say to other
agents because I built up that
relationship with them yes I know what
to say to them but at the same time I
built up those relationships but like
you said once you buy that first one
with that agent they will keep coming
back to you if they know you've got the
money or you're or you've got the
clients they will come to you another
thing as well I do when I ring I did
this the other day I don't know if you
were you at the course yeah when I rang
up yeah a lot of stuff happened so but
one of the things that happened was I
said to someone give me an area where
you think it'll be really hard to find a
deal and they said the name of some
little village yeah I think in Surrey
was it wasn't it yeah some little names
little village and I went all right cool
and I typed in the name of the village
and I put a state agents and about 10 or
30 just came up and I saw ah that estate
agency who's a nationwide brand and
there's loads like Dixon's best of
weaves I think he was handsome it was
Hampton Hamptons and I just rang them up
in that area and I said hey I've
previously actually bought through
Hamptons before in such and such a
branch I'm looking to buy something in
your area and now it's like oh this guy
has done business with us before it
might have not been in that area with
that estate agency but the fact that
it's the same chain
and his whole tone changed in there at
first he was like you know really
standoffish and um how can I help oh
you're an investor looking to buy deals
and then as soon as I bought actually
through you before she's like oh oh
okay how can I help you Mr Lee oh I can
see on the system that you have so use
other deals as as credibility to get
your foot in the door yeah that's
exactly what you need to do and once you
build those relationships it's
maintaining those relationships yeah
with those people I think a lot of
people don't realize but you have to
maintain relationships property you can
build your portfolio you can build your
your skills by building up relationships
so it's really important to have the
right people around you yeah at all time
and and those people who aren't right
for you take them out of the equations
as quickly as possible yeah but having
the right people around you is the most
important thing and another thing is as
well when you ring up an agent and you
say this is what I'm looking for if
you've got anything if they say no they
haven't got anything and I've got
nothing available don't just think okay
cool contact them again like every week
and everything is a lot of investors
this is one of the things that ticks me
off I used to doing a cringe now when
I'd call on the state agent
I used when they'd ask me for that um
for my details if they'd say oh what's
your details and we'll put you on the
mailing list I used to kind of like
think I don't want to give out my email
and get spammed no thanks but how stupid
is that they're literally saying well
listen to your criteria and we'll keep
you posted if anything comes up and
you're like no what so now I'll ring up
and I'm like hey take my email you want
to book me in for a mortgage appointment
let me come to the office have a
mortgage appointment my job when I was
an estate agent used to be when I'd book
a viewing I'd have to like upsell them
to come and meet the mortgage broker
everyone when they say to me do you want
to come and be our mortgage advisor I
used to be like no now I'm like I have
already got a broker but I'm very happy
to come in and sit with your broker and
have a chat and if you can beat my
broker fine that gives me now an
opportunity to go to the office have a
cup of coffee show them that I've got
the finance so my whole mentality after
being an estate agent for six months
just changed you're from that world yeah
you're an estate agent but you're also
an investor do you think it gives you an
advantage being an estate agent also
being 100 it does give me the advantage
it was that experience that able that
helped me realize these are the next
steps I need to make sure that I'm
saying the right thing I'm doing the
right thing but I know exactly how they
work moving forward even though yes now
I own my own estate agency it's making
sure that I know the criteria and how to
do it but yes it does certainly help
having that experience what do you think
as well about do you know you've got the
different strategies like lease options
and rent to rent and brr and the
different things when you go into an
estate agent generally speaking they're
not going to be clued up on those
strategies you can't just walk into it I
don't even say when I'm going into an
estate agency generally speaking unless
they really get it like you I'm not
going to tell them I'm looking for a brr
I'm gonna tell them I'm looking for a
flip yeah because everyone gets a flip
yeah yeah buying a house doing upsetting
it looking for a flip obviously I need
to make a bit of profit if it works for
a flip it works for a brr probably so
it's also understanding the language
lease option agreements you can't walk
into an estate agent and say could I buy
it now and pay for it later on a lease
option agreement none of them will
understand they won't I mean you just
did want to I've done two two leased
options yeah and that's that's purely
just based on you know I have clients
who are in a situation that they needed
some help so I'm able to help them
potentially offer them more money in the
future something that's favorable to
them and me but at the same time I'm
giving them a guaranteed rent for a
period of time so it helps secure them
and and gives them that period of time
where now I can help them fixing their
mortgage for the next five years yeah
and then five years later I'm able to
purchase the property for the agreed
price wow that's awesome and again this
is something that I've learned from you
Samuel I didn't know this I've heard of
it but until I came in your course I
didn't realize how how it works if
anyone doesn't understand what a
purchase option agreement is could you
just like summarize why it's good for
them why it's good for you it's allowing
you know if you've got someone or you
know someone who's in a situation who
who can't either afford their mortgage
or or is struggling or something's going
on in their life but they don't want to
necessarily sell in this market this
Market turning into a buyer's market it
is it's turning into a buyer's market so
a lot of landlords a lot of my clients
who are worried about not making the
money that they may be able to borrowers
if you can do something decent for them
and give them maybe 10 or 15 000 pound
more than what the current market is
giving then that's beneficial for them
but you're not having to pay for it
until five years later or seven years
later depending on what deal you do with
them if you know their mortgages let's
say 700 pounds and you're giving them I
don't know a thousand pounds or Eleven
Hundred pounds they've got for the next
five years guaranteed 400 pound profit
coming from that deal and they've got
that for the next five years and and and
then at the end of the five years you've
bought it off them for the price that
you agree today that's awesome it's
really beneficial and again Samuel is
this is all down to you well it's an
honor man it's an honor thank you so
much there's nothing more rewarding than
like share sharing something and
explaining the secret passing it works
and then people straight away bang bang
going and getting results because not
just yourself or you know on the Monday
night masterminds it's like every week
for me it's quite it's quite humble and
seeing the success and it's been great I
think there's so many things that I've
learned over the courses that I'm now
implementing one by one into making
those changes and yeah and reducing my
cost down one of the biggest things for
me in my business was costs cost savings
there are a lot of ideas you've put
towards us and send right these are the
things we can do to implement so that's
that's just important how did you find
your speech that you gave the other week
because I put you on the spot slightly
but I asked you there was 300 property
investors and I said to you hey would
you like to deliver a 10-minute speech
in front of these 200 people and just
share your experience with that property
and you did and it was amazing you
stormed it and everyone loved it but how
did you find that I'm not very confident
because I'm quite nervous so yeah it was
uh you only give me 20 minutes but no I
really enjoyed it because I was able to
put across what are my experiences and
what I've been doing and and what I've
learned and um yes it was very much I
was put on the spot but I'm a people's
person so when I someone's telling me
something I pick it up it absorbs I
absorb it straight away so yeah I was
just I just felt like I had to tell
everyone how I felt with the experience
so far and uh it's been fantastic I
think if you're not being stretched and
you're not growing then then you're
dying aren't you yeah so it's great to
see you even now after so many years
have been in the business pushing
yourself being stretched with the estate
agency it's it's difficult I think a lot
of people don't realize it's quite cut
throat everyone's out for the same sort
of business you're really trying your
best to make it work I wish that every
estate agent in the country at least did
my one pound crash course because I
think if estate agents knew how it works
they got it they'd be able to find us
better deals 100 I think that all the
state agents should be coming to your
course and learning at least the one
pound course you know what I'm saying
you don't have to do the advanced
courses I haven't been on the one pound
course but I think just going straight
on and and going on the academy made me
benefit so much more and and being on
you know the four days intensives yeah I
think that just you know absolutely was
mind-blowing well I'm really pleased to
know you not and you know what you've
been a massive asset to the academy as
well so I really am grateful for you
sharing your story you didn't have to
give up your time today but you did and
I hope that you inspire a lot of people
so thank you so much pleasure
[Music]